hi I'm levar burton this is my throne of  books and these are some of the most  beautiful quotes in the dresser  at any rate that is happiness to be  dissolved into something complete and  great isn't it pretty to think so he  stepped down trying not to look long at  her as if she were the son yet he saw  her like the Sun even without whatever  our souls are made of his and mine are  the same there is a sense in which we  are all each other's consequences let  the wild rumpus start you don't have to  live forever you just have to live and  the rest is rust and Stardust a dream  all a dream that ends in nothing and  leaves the sleeper where he lay down but  I wish you to know and you inspired him  Journeys End in lovers meeting  everything was beautiful and nothing  hurt